all right so what I have is basically a
case of you can't believe your eyes
so you know in a lot of the stuff that
we look at in math we look for patterns
right and we try it for a few examples
and if we see a pattern then we think oh
maybe this continues on right but it's
not like a proof it's not a convincing
argument and so what I want to talk
about today is an example of when the
pattern just completely misleads us if
you take like a random number is it more
likely to have an odd number of prime
factors or an even number of prime
factors that's the basic question
se10 the way that it breaks down into
prime numbers is that it's the product
of two which is prime and five which is
also prime so it has two prime factors
okay so it has an even number of prime
factors but of course if I take any
prime number like say five or two or
whatever then it only has one prime
factor and so it has an odd number of
prime factor you're gonna see when I
write it down in a minute that I'm gonna
ignore totally the numbers that have
repeated prime factors so I'm gonna
define a function and I'm gonna use this
notation because all the mathematicians
will yell at me if I don't so this is
the letter mu and what this function is
gonna do is it's gonna take in a number
and it's gonna output 1 if n my number
has an even number of prime factors so
like 10 we talked about that example
because 2 & 5 are its prime factors but
also none repeated it's gonna give me
the value minus 1 if all this stuff is
still true except I have an odd number
of prime factors any prime number would
be given the assignment of the value
minus 1 under this function will give it
the value 0 if a prime is repeated when
we factor the number let's do some
hands-on work here because this is kind
of a complicated definition does a get a
zero if the prime because sometimes you
get a factorization where a certain
factor is repeated
yeah another one just appears once oh
yeah 2 times 2 times 2 times 5 yeah yeah
that would count as a zero right so that
would count as a zero if any time we
have a repeat then we assign zero to
this thing yeah let's look at some some
concrete examples because I think it's
easy once you start working with it
but hard to talk about abstractly okay
so here's my numbers and I'll look at
the values of this function mu so let's
forget about zero I don't want to even
think about it let's start with two okay
a prime number it has one prime factor
which is an odd number so we assign it a
minus 1 3 same deal for this is the bad
news situation where we have a repeated
prime factor because it's 2 times 2 so
we assign it 0 5 is prime it gets a
minus 1 6 factors into 2 times 3 that's
2 number of prime factors and so we
assign it a 1 so let me just fill in a
few more here
eight takes zero nine is a square it
takes zero ten we already talked about
it has two prime factors and you can
keep going right alright so if I want to
know which happens more often all I have
to do is add up the values of this
function because it's negative when I
have an odd number of prime factors it's
positive when I have an even number of
prime factors what I should do is just
add up the minus ones and the plus ones
and just see if I get something positive
or negative and we started the ledger on
which side of the ledger am I on and
this will tell me what's going on what
do I get when I add up these numbers so
in the first initial computation there's
a few more numbers with an odd number of
prime factors than an even number of
prime factors so I don't have an answer
for you about like what happens more
often because it's a little you have to
be a little careful to formulate what
you mean because you're sort of doing
this trade-off going back and forth
between minus one and plus one and then
you can always sort of find another
prime number so there's a minus one but
then okay you can multiply that 1 by 2
so then there's a plus 1 so you keep
going through all of the whole numbers
and you're gonna get lots of minus ones
and you're gonna get lots of ones so
there's a lot of cancellation ok and so
what I mean is that this sum should
always be pretty small minus two is
smaller than seven by a decent amount
you can imagine as you keep going on the
numbers get really big but the sum
doesn't get so big is it gonna hover
around zeros like so that's the question
so first of all you can show that it's
not gonna hover around zero it's gonna
zigzag like crazy actually
but the conjecture the thing that people
thought was true for a long time was
that it's never gonna be larger than the
square root of the number that you've
gone up to so if I do this and I go up
through this process of adding together
all these minus ones and Plus Ones and
say I stopped at a million then the
thought is well okay whatever number I
get it's some number between minus 1,000
and positive 1,000 cuz that's the square
root of a million but it could be on
either side of zero it could be either
side of zero and
in fact it is known that it switches
back and forth infinitely often so
that's like a really complicated like
thing to think about yeah but but so it
could get really hard I could get up
into the thousands and then it could
drop to the minus a thousand that's
right yeah and just zigzagging back and
forth sort of living around zero but in
a really complicated way and so the
thought was that okay it's complicated
but because I have all this cancellation
it can never be too big it has to be
between minus the square root of the
number and the square root of the number
so this is known as merchants conjecture
and because this is called merchants
function this sum that I'm adding up and
it was thought to be true for a long
time and it turns out that it's not true
but it's crazy because if you do this I
mean we can now compute really far it
and you go billions and billions and
billions of numbers out and it still
satisfies this square root bound what is
now known is that there is a counter
example to this conductor you eventually
zigzag out past the square root of the
number but we also know that we have
some terrible terrible bounds on how big
the number has to be to actually do this
so it's something like 10 to the 10 to
the 40 there's something like that so do
we know the exact number where first
breaks the rule well I mean if we knew
it we could never write it down because
we would need all of the atoms in the
universe to write it so no the answer is
no we don't know like we'd have no way
to describe the first time that it
happened but we know it exists but we
know it exists so despite all
computational evidence that could ever
be produced in the history and future
life of the universe we know that it
still fails to be true so what we're
looking at is a picture of this function
where we're adding up these minus ones
and plus ones and going along with the
integers and so as you can see what's
happening is that the as we add more and
more terms to the sum we go back and
forth here zero we go back and forth
around zero we start kind of more
negative by the way that's kind of fun
to notice because there's lots of prime
numbers that are small so we go back and
forth around zero and but no matter how
much back and forth we do we're not
getting anywhere close to this boundary
given by the square root of the number
so we zigzag back and forth positive and
negative positive and negative but no
matter how large we get we don't even
come close to approaching that boundary
you can't draw that graph for the point
where it gets near the square root
because
numbers is too big yeah that's right the
numbers are too big I mean they just
can't even be written down much less
computed but one day that that's zigzag
that Alps mountain range will break free
of that square root loop it will but I
don't think we're gonna be around to see
it unfortunately does it just break away
from that square root roll what is a
blast faster so that's a really
complicated question we don't know the
answer to that we know it doesn't go too
far past it but actually the reason why
people were initially or one interesting
thing initially noticed about this
question is that if it had been true if
this false thing had been true it would
imply the Riemann hypothesis which is
this really big open question in
mathematics that's thought to be like
very difficult and very strong so
understanding the growth of the the size
of this mertens function is actually
really intimately connected to some of
the most difficult problems in
mathematics and I think there was at
some point some hope of proving the
Riemann hypothesis by proving this
conjecture so when it was shown to be
false we lost that hope I love that
there's some number floating out there
when the rule first gets broken but we
could never even write it down yeah
that's right I mean we could never even
arraigned I keep going back to atoms in
the universe because that's what makes
me sort of happy and blows my mind right
we could never even arrange all of the
atoms in the universe to describe like
they could never be lined up in any
computable way but we know it's there
and it's like finite it's an exact
number yeah yeah it's the only way we
can describe it as the first number that
fails mertens conjecture has that got a
name is it is a code like his his number
or something no that's a good point I
don't think it has a name maybe we
should name it that's my new favorite
number
so maybe you go to the gym to get your
body in better shape but what about your
brain how do you get your mind in better
shape
well how about trying brilliant with its
enormous library of courses puzzles
interactive content covering all sorts
of mathematical and scientific subjects
and don't worry there's plenty of prime
number stuff if that's your thing
how can you resist this now look
everything has been carefully curated
and designed it's not about what you get
right or what you get wrong
it's about guiding you along this
beautifully manicured journey to make
you a better thinker why don't you check
them out go to brilliant org slash
numberphile that'll get you 20% off
their premium subscription and that
unlocks everything all the good stuff
and trust me you're gonna be busy a long
time with all of this it's brilliant org
slash numberphile check them out and now
thanks to them for supporting the show
and when I say that I'm going to
approximate pie in the Mandelbrot set I
don't mean that I'm going to approximate
PI on this picture here I mean that I'm
gonna cook up a bunch of numbers that
have to do with the Mandelbrot set that
approximate pi